welcome to this video playing DD DD from
France frequent opponent really let's
see what is the score oh I'm leading 83
with no draws ok but let's see what we
get play 24 for a change ok let's do the
same juco piano Italian game I have
rough idea what to do i mean i play you
for your five four black for a number of
years I one day I can maybe I can try to
delay castling for a moment trying to
get night f1 g3 and early can Nyjah for
sometimes sir is smooth but here i can i
can just castle ok if a plane night
everyone is there no chief Forman maybe
I can play 93 though should be ok or
maybe Knight g4 I have even deform maybe
could be a bit shaky though this
position always just playing d5
interesting yeah I think this is in fact
a possible way to play Queenie too young
he was threatening you for some in 93
the exchange Queen d1 this very am very
harmless looking at least
jaron well normally black should be a
right okay in this type of positions
he's got very healthy structure before I
am deforest an ambitious move but not a
bad one certainly ciao taking is
probably leading to nothing I'll just
turn ig3 where else um should it go some
nigeria's perfectly okay I think and
okay yeah 11 black idea is to take on c3
and then play before trying to fight for
the default square yeah but it's not I
mean it's possible but not the end of
the world for me if he if he does that
take stakes be for Bishop t2 should
still be okay um well maybe he's got
Bishop g4 trying to do even more for the
default square okay maybe I should have
but ok take stakes before I can also
take on before yeah this is better
actually rendering the whole idea i
think useless or even take stakes be for
Bishop a fourth even better now okay so
that's not really a problem for me
that's good news maybe you can play
Bishop g4 is taking lots of time here i
mean i'm not i'm not very quick in those
games but here's some taking even more
time i wonder if i can think of Bishop
g5 here after he has played Bishop g6 it
threatens night age five and there is
there's always this idea with the
possible piece sacrifice I'm what I'm
talking about is h6 Bishop h4 g5 takes
on g5 but takes takes various Queen
Queen D
and you can always take on c32 to
relieve some pressure yeah okay not not
really on some play useful move okay so
he wants to exchange here hmm now maybe
I don't want to trade myself that's what
wouldn't be too nice strategically I
think about night h4 to g5 this is maybe
an idea or directly no I have five okay
can take after that so let's put this
night on your five
after night after the night is arriving
on f5 Bishop g5 firm is becoming more of
an idea as h6 g5 is entirely impossible
due to h6 hanging ok he's going for this
positional idea should be too was what I
was thinking or I can take I mean he
wants to play 94 this lame yeah not
greater not great ok I probably must do
that it's not the end of the world
really but he's got this square on d4
but I have some play on the c4 so what
I'm talking about is this type of
position this is not not so bad a rook
is nice on see one and a half night f5
coming ninety-fourth I was Queen e4 h 4
is not hanging ok here we got a position
that ok he's attacking be 3 night a 5 or
not
it's also rooke a six maybe a book a six
taking a six so we will take the three
year but still that's a very unstable
position
but I didn't expect but ok it's not bad
probably ok but still a f9f five coming
the rook on a six can be a piece that is
helpful in the attack
okay here 2g4 not sure what this is
doing I can just hide more dainty form
but the night night to see five will be
an issue clearly a check okay try to get
something going with that I don't know I
don't really have much time right f5 is
not working Quincy form maybe I cannot
really calculate this King takes neither
five meters easy but maybe my my nights
are just stranded that's possible ok on
chat now this speculating that you
cannot take or won't dare to take and
write f six now you can take on f2 but
i'm not sure if it is so great Queen
edge forms are total mess
yeah I'm not sure that I'm threatening
much here to be honest this is this one
mmm for ya
I'm have seven is some going down don't
know check check black market what was
happening here I've got nothing on the
clock yeah no idea what was going on I
could have taken it actually yeah but
okay it's just a premium fest no idea no
idea really haven't probably objectively
I probably lost them but it's a it's of
course very very complicated yeah I went
here which is probably not good young
but I came whoopsie six maybe rook
Bishop b6 is now giving us good by the
computer yeah it seems that my nights
are not doing doing that much it's and
it's check with the sister it looks
interesting store let's see g 60 light
h5 is some is a move interesting yeah
that makes lots of sense actually it
threatens night to h6 year and he cannot
take check both nights because of made
hmm interesting
the computer gives this line check check
then the smooth probably intending f4
with white having a slight edge whatever
that means yeah yet but this seems that
the the positional deficits that
position has maybe a compensated by this
direct attack here it seems that black
is better check this okay this loses he
can take on age 68 head the hunch that
he could do that but okay it was just a
gamble um check this seems to be still
okay okay yeah this looks so much more
um yeah normal let's say leading to the
only a sort of Perpetual GM computer
wants to play king g7 allowing the
perpetual I'm not threatening something
terrible he okay well I've got
everything covered so it's not the clear
what black should do but I don't see my
threat maybe Knight f6 to h5 is this a
threat I look at you 60 that's a brutal
move that's really a brutal move Wow and
wide wins yeah that's tough to see with
a limited time this is jang i see'em
check winning the house and meeting in a
couple of moves so I was always somewhat
tricky but chat ok he could have taken
and here we are just a check just hoping
for the best while black is totally
winning here rook g6 as a cute move
nice okay I had 10 10 seconds needed to
cover and Bishop e3 now is winning the
game yeah he didn't she didn't send
anything and now decided to try to win
were seven against five I guess okay
well he's got four points for the rookie
I'm so when we can can try would check
with just a couple of seconds I would
have played that and okay what will win
this those pawns are going nowhere yeah
well complicated stuff alright thanks
for watching